>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Michelle Bickert: Thank you
everybody for joining us today
and for moving down
closer to the front.
We really appreciate it and
are happy to enjoy you and see
if you're really, really excited
or if you maybe make it easier
to throw tomatoes at us.
I don't know.
I hope everybody's having
a good DPLA Fest so far.
Whoo! We are here to talk to
you today and give you an update
on library ebook platforms.
As some of you may remember
from last year we were able
to do a really intensive ebook
workshop thanks to generous funding
from the [inaudible] Foundation.
And a lot of good work
came out of that.
I think most importantly I got
hired, so hold your applause.
And so I wanted to give you at least
a quick update on where we are,
and then introduce my colleagues
who will talk more of the state
of ebooks and libraries
more broadly.
So where are we now a
year after DPLA Fest 2015?
I've got a couple of our projects
that DPLA has been
working on up there.
Open Ebooks has been mentioned
I know quite a few times today
and we're going to talk about
it even more as we go through.
And I'm sure that Micah's probably
going to talk about that as well.
I'll just mention briefly
what DPLA's role has been
in Open Ebooks as a partner.
We put together a curation core of
the nation's top school librarians,
librarians working with youth,
and they curated the 6,000 books
that we have available
in Open Ebooks.
They were able to take those
publisher donations and pick
out what it is that
students really want as well
as reflect the diversity.
We also run the social media for it,
we help convene the community
conversations around it,
we're helping to lead conversations
around accessibility in ebooks,
and try to improve even more some of
that native functionality that comes
through ePUB and working
with Readium.
And we really see that all of the
press that's been around Open Ebooks
as an opportunity to
help further some
of these initiatives
in the ebook community.
And DPLA is helping to lead
that conversation along
with our partners NYPL
and First Books.
Also, I have up there a
little graphic for LEAP,
the Library eContent Access
Project, which is funded by IMLS.
And DPLA's role in that is to be
the, again, the community convener.
We're trying to figure out what
our role is in ebooks again
as we've worked in the past
year, and so we're helping
to organize the conversations
that are going to go
around creating a library-owned
marketplace
which again Micah's going
to talk to a bit more later.
With that idea though, and
DPLA organizing these community
conversations, we're
also working on a sort
of broader ebook working group,
a broader ebook community,
and this came out of the
conversations last year.
So how can we create an umbrella for
everybody who's working in ebooks
to come together and share
all of their information,
share what they're working on?
We want to be able to
streamline the effort.
If somebody in Massachusetts
is working with a publisher
and somebody in Texas is working
with a publisher how can we make
sure that they're connecting
with each other and talking
about what [inaudible] they
were able to make with content.
We had some great discussions
over the last week for those of us
who were able to join at the Public
Library Association as well as some
of us got together yesterday as the
LEAP partners, and are really trying
to see where we all fit in there.
And I think that those
conversations are going really well.
I also have a little
graphic down there.
DPLA has about two million items
that are categorized as books
within our site, and we're looking
at how we can open up that content.
And there's going to be a whole
session right after this talking
about how we can try to open up
the content that our hubs have
and turn those into
accessible ebooks.
So I'll just quickly add
going back to what I said
about the ebook working group,
we want voices to get involved.
We want people to feel that they
have a community that they can come
into and talk about
ebooks, learn more,
be connected with the resources
that they need for their library.
So we have up here on the screen
a couple of different places
where you can look to get involved.
We're still sort of figuring
out what our best options
are going to be.
We've got a Google Plus
community, a working group listserv
and a Wiki page that posts our
findings, our final products.
I would recommend going again to the
dp.la website, Get Involved, Ebooks.
We're really trying to
get this to bubble up
and making it easier
for you all to connect.
So please just get in touch with
me if you know that you want
to be involved, if it's a
conversation that you want
to be part of and I can make
sure that you are plugged in.
I'm Michelle.
You can find me on the DPLA website.
Our emails are pretty easy.
So with that I'll introduce
my colleagues who are here
to give you an update from
their world of ebooks.
We have Christine Peterson who
is the Amigos eShelf Manager
for Amigos Library
Services in Texas.
Greg Pronevitz.
Oops, you guys switched
seats, spots on me.
Greg Pronevitz on the end there
who is the Executive Director
of the Massachusetts Library System.
And Micah May who is the
Director of Business Development
for the New York Public Library.
And with that I'll pass
it over to Christine.
>> Christine Peterson:
Thanks for coming.
I am Chris Peterson.
I'm the Project Manager or Program
Manager for Amigos eShelf Project.
But fortunately or
unfortunately I'm not here to talk
to you about our project.
Talk to me afterwards.
Okay? No laughter?
No nothing?
[ Laughter ]
Okay. So my role today is actually
not to talk to you about us
but to give you a little
bit of history,
to give you the library-created
platforms that went before us
and where they are right now.
But first I want to give
you the three reasons
that libraries started doing this.
And it really goes down to
Douglas County which I will talk
about a little bit more in detail.
There were three reasons
that Douglas County decided
to create their own
instead of continue
with the commercial vendors.
The first was the loss of
ownership of the titles
that they were subscribing
to at the time.
Also, the increased price.
There was a specific
incidence with OverDrive
that really turned
the corner for them.
And the third was the requirement
of their patrons having to learn
yet another user interface.
And with all three of those things
they decided we can do this.
And so I'm going to start with
Douglas County who's our first.
Douglas County decided to integrate
their ebooks into their ILS,
the one you're looking
at right here.
I have about a minute per
here so I'm going to move
through these pretty quickly.
They were the first ones that
said, "You know, we can do this."
And they went to IMLS and
they were fortunate enough
to get an IMLS grant to
help fund this change.
They did decide to do what we all
claim we want to do which is try
to bring everything together instead
of having silos and they were able
to bring everything
together within their ILS.
Of course, they had
technical resources
to be able to back that up.
So the question is where
are they right now.
Oh, by the way, everything
they did was open source.
If you go to the Evoke--
e, v, o, k, e--
website you will get
everything you need
to know to do this for yourself.
I do want to tell you that
where they are now is kind
of questionable.
Actually it's probably
not really questionable.
They are not moving forward.
There have been a number
of staffing changes
at Douglas County particularly
in the administrative area,
and their focus has been
moved to something else.
Now I say that telling you
that they still have a server,
an Adobe content server, sitting
there and it is still working.
They have not yet turned it off but
they are not moving forward with it.
I also want to make mention here
that when they created
this they created it
without web-based ordering.
I'll come back to that
explaining why that's important.
Right after that, well, within
a year after that, Marmot,
which is a consortium that
includes Douglas County,
it's a multi-type library
consortium in Colorado,
they decided to move
forward on this.
And they created their own.
Now they're a consortium so
they were not just dealing
with a single library at this point.
They decided to use View Find,
which is an open source discovery
system, as their interface.
So they already had an existing ILS
but they used View Find
as that discovery piece.
So that when they added the ebooks
they were also doing the same thing
as Douglas County they were
just doing it the different way.
Douglas County used their ILS,
Marmot used the View Find interface.
So they already had a very
robust ILS that was going.
They went ahead and included ebooks.
They also integrated
ebooks with other resources.
They are not just dealing
with OverDrive.
They deal with multiple
ebook aggregators
and they bring all
of that in to one.
They do an incredible job there.
They also upgraded the
View Find functionality
so much that it forked.
So now you have View Find Plus
and you have the View
Find Community versions.
They also have decided not to
move forward with the ebook side
of this with the platform side.
Mainly because they're
changing their focus,
and into other types
of functionality.
Now the interesting thing is
their Adobe content server sits
at Douglas County.
They share that server.
So as long as Douglas County's
server is up Marmot is still up
but they're just not doing
anything with the service.
I don't believe, last time I
heard there was not a timeframe
for Douglas County to take that
server down but I would imagine
in the next year it might be down.
Marmot is right now starting to move
those ebooks that they purchased
on to other commercial platforms
that they have access to.
Taking a little bit out of, I was
trying to do from oldest to newest
but I want to continue
with Colorado.
This is probably one
of the newer projects.
This is the Evoke 2.0 Project.
And the reason Colorado did
this was because of the lack
of web-based ordering which
made it really difficult
for the smaller libraries
to be able to join.
Too much time, they didn't
have the resources to do it.
So they went back to
IMLS and got a grant
to actually create an
end-to-end solution
which included not
only web-based ordering
but also included a
really nice interface.
It was a compliment to the projects
that had already been
going on in Colorado.
And they did do this, they
got an agreement with Odilo
and Odilo went ahead and changed
their software to do this.
Unfortunately it was
never implemented.
So it sits in Colorado
and right now it sits
at the Colorado State Library.
To this point nothing
has been done with it.
That doesn't mean that
something won't be.
But right now it's been a
year, maybe a little bit more,
that the software hasn't been used.
So we don't know where
this one is going.
We'll see.
I know that there's
a lot of interest
at the Colorado State Library to
do something with it and to be part
of the ebook work that's being done.
The next group that came forward was
sorry, was Califa, sorry about that.
Califa is a consortium
out of California.
It's a public library consortium.
And they are the third.
So we have Douglas County, we have
Marmot and then we have Califa.
And all of these people I'm talking
about, you know those of us who came
after stand on the
shoulders of these people.
I mean they did incredible work.
They did incredible time,
experience, money that went
into this so even though
I'm telling you that some
of these projects have
stopped that doesn't mean
that we don't still value
the work that they did,
and that continues with Califa.
So they are a consortium.
There are multiple ILSs there
that they work through and with.
They use the View Find interface
that Marmot has created.
They also started out with
a single-shared collection
and now they have moved to not
only a single-shared collection
but also collections
for each library.
You might notice that
I have a note up there
that the Kansas State
Library is part of Califa.
And so those of you who are in the
know know that there was an issue
between Califa, I mean, sorry,
Kansas State Library and OverDrive
when OverDrive upped their
cost by 700% the result
of that was Kansas
pulled their books out,
and they are now a Califa member.
So there was an interesting
story behind that.
So where is Califa right now?
Califa is moving forward.
My gosh, yes.
You don't want to get
in front of Califa
because they're going
to run you over.
So there's a lot going on,
and there's Paula right there.
You know, right there.
So Califa is moving forward.
Now the key right here
you might notice
that there's no web-based ordering.
And I say that there's no
web-based ordering yet,
because Califa is looking
into ways to bring that in.
And, again, if you have that it
makes it easier for a library
to be able to use the service.
So then I move on to ours and I
wish I could spend an hour here
but I won't.
I'll spend just a couple of minutes.
We were next.
We were the fourth ones.
And because we stand
on the shoulders
of everybody else what
did we include?
We included web-based ordering.
So this is just a real
quick view of that.
We are a multi-type consortium.
We span, historically,
we span six states.
When we decided to do this we
decided that choice was our,
flexibility in choice is
what we're looking for.
So when libraries come to us they
choose where they want these ebooks
to show up, we have
interlibrary loan agreements
with almost all the publishers.
We're looking at multiple
licensing agreements.
I mean, there's a lot of
things that we're doing mainly
because we're straddling both public
and academic school and special.
So where are we headed?
We are, can I say right behind
Califa, or right with Califa.
I mean, yeah, we're
moving forward as well.
The next one is the
Montana State Library.
I did not even know they
were doing anything.
I'm so embarrassed, until
about six or seven months ago.
But Montana, and the
reason I didn't know is
because Montana was
doing it internally
and it took them a
long time to do it.
There were a lot of
technical challenges.
They didn't have a lot of staff.
They didn't have a lot of money.
But they wanted to see
if they could do it.
So they did a pilot project
and their authentication
came just through SIP.
They didn't do any
other authentication.
They're dealing primarily with
ebooks that are about Montana
or written by Montana authors.
There's nothing really
happening with it right now.
It is up and running.
They have 30 titles which
tells you it's a pilot.
They are looking to broaden that
or possibly to become part of LEAP,
or to look at Califa or Amigos.
But they are looking to see
how they can become part
of this conversation.
Whether it is to keep what they've
got or to hook onto somebody else.
The next one I have is Pennsylvania.
There are two libraries-- Oil City
and Meadville public libraries,
which are about 30 miles
apart in Pennsylvania.
Meadville has a tradition
of using open source.
They were one of the first
[inaudible] libraries,
and they do a lot of
open source there,
and they give back to the community.
And they looked at this one
and they said, "We can do this.
We're going to do it as a pilot."
And their hope was that the
Pennsylvania State Library would
look at it and take it on.
That was the hope.
You might notice that it says
"Ready to test with libraries."
They originally gave
themselves six months to do it.
Sixteen months later
they're starting to test.
Let me just say it takes a
little bit longer than you think.
So this was built as
a proof of concept
and they have two publishers.
They brought in Gutenberg
and they brought in ABDO.
So they are also up and running.
We'll see where they go.
The last one that I have
here is Connecticut.
Although Connecticut's not a
platform, Connecticut is important
because they were given $2
million to build a platform,
or possibly to support a platform.
So there's a really
good story behind this.
I don't have time to give you,
but LJ has an excellent story
about how this all worked.
And you would all smile at
how the state process works.
But they are now looking, and
they are intimately involved
in the LEAP project.
So we'll probably see them
come out with something.
The last big thing I do want
to mention is the National Ebook
Platform and that's kind of LEAP,
sorry, that's kind of what LEAP is.
I just want to say here that we
are not sure what this is yet.
This is still a continuing
discussion of what this might be
but the idea is it might be nice to
have a single place run by libraries
or run by a non-profit that
could bring down costs.
It could reflect the values that
we have when it comes to licensing
and how we deal with ebooks.
So we're looking forward to
seeing where this one goes.
And I want to end this just by
saying that those of who are as old
as I do and you remember going from
manual card catalogs to computers,
and those who remember
internet coming
and you remember CDs going out,
this is another transition we're in.
And as frustrating as it is it is
an exciting time to be part of this.
So I just want to leave
you with that.
All of us who work
in this ebooks space,
and we hope that you
guys will join us,
we're all very excited
about what's coming.
There's a lot of different
projects out there
and they are doing a
lot of different things.
And who knows where
it's going to end up.
But it's a great time
to be involved.
And with that I'll let,
let's see, is it your turn?
It's all yours.
[ Clapping ]
>> Greg Pronevitz: Thanks Christine.
Can you hear me in the back there?
Okay. I can't really
see if [inaudible].
I'm Greg Pronevitz,
Executive Director
of the Massachusetts Library System.
And I'm here to talk about
a survey that I distributed
but it was developed in
collaboration with Michelle
from DPLA, Valerie Horton from
Minitex, and Veronda Pitchford
from Rails where we're gearing up
to do a presentation at ALA Orlando.
And this is sort of the preliminary
look at our survey results.
I presented results
of an earlier survey
at a Minitex webinar last year.
And if anyone's interested in seeing
that my email address is up here.
I'd be happy to send
you the link for that.
So first of all we had 35
respondents to the survey.
And I only have 10 minutes
to talk about them today
so it won't be comprehensive.
But if you have a consortial ebook
platform or program that you would
like to be included in future
surveys please get in touch with me
and we'll get you a survey.
In our survey of the
35 respondents four
of them had either national
or multi-state reach.
Twenty of them were statewide
programs of one way, shape or form.
And 11 of them were
regional programs.
This map, I decided to put
in a political statement.
What I see here is both
conventions become contested,
Trump and Bernie switch
sides, and here's what we get.
But really this is the red states
are statewide ebook projects
that are not OverDrive.
The blue states are statewide
ebook projects that are OverDrive.
And statewide is taken very
loosely, 90% availability.
The black states I don't
believe have statewide projects
or did not respond to my surveys.
Missouri and Virginia both have
multiple statewide projects.
Here's what the 2014 survey
and the 2015 survey look like.
The one on the right is
the newer one with more red
and I added one blue in
Ohio that I learned about.
Of these consortia some of
them gave enough demographics
that I could talk about their
primary focus either public,
academic or multi-type.
None of them were primarily
K-12 or primarily special.
The participating libraries were
chiefly K through 12 with well
over 2,500, public with about
2,500, academic in the 500 range.
This is a total aggregate
not any one.
Total number of libraries
participating is over 5,700.
The tiny number of 13 special
or other libraries often
included a state library.
The population served
reported by those
who reported populations served
total 58 million population.
So these consortial ebook projects
really have a lot of reach.
I did a little scattergram
of when these projects began
and of those reported you can
see they're really bunched
up around 2011 through 2013
there were a lot started.
And one started this year.
So congratulations.
We asked our colleagues about
publisher agreements and three
of the projects talked
about having more
than 100 publisher agreements each.
Amigos, [inaudible] and Techshare.
And those libraries and others
that were interested in it all felt
that the trend of working directly
with publishers was on the rise.
We asked folks about which
aggregators they're using.
OverDrive was the big one.
And this survey certainly didn't
include every single OverDrive
consortium out there by any
stretch of the imagination.
So the local OverDrive users will
probably grow way beyond this once
we get a wider reach
with the survey.
EBSCO came in second in this case.
Netlibrary was mentioned
specifically in a couple of cases.
Baker and Taylor were next.
BiblioBoard, Bibliotheca or 3M, EBL
and TotalBoox all came in with two
And then there were six others
that were just a sprinkling of this
that and the other thing.
We asked respondents about
licensing uniqueness,
and this was their own opinion
about what was unique about things.
And one of the things that
we noticed in our own program
in Massachusetts, we have a
Baker and Taylor agreement
with statewide access,
and we found that Baker
and Taylor really helped us open
the door to some Big Five publishers
that weren't available
when we started.
Unlimited use of recorded books
in BiblioBoard were other
interesting features.
We asked folks about what kind
of unique content they had
and they listed languages or
literacy in some local content.
Other data, of the
groups that reported
about 900,000 total unique
titles are available among them.
I don't have the number of
how many actually reported
but it certainly wasn't 35.
And of the ones that reported annual
spending it totaled $10 million.
And that, again, was just a
small percentage of respondents.
Not everybody did that.
We need to get a better
handle on that, too.
The funding formulas that these
groups use to gather contributions
from either state funding,
grant funding,
local funding really varied.
There's no way to really report
a trend in that at this point.
So I wanted to talk about some of
the conclusions from the comments
that people made during this.
And one of the common themes
in "What was your vision
for your project" and the
theme common throughout all
of that was expanding access to
more content for more patrons.
The challenges that people were
dealing with were meeting holds,
the costs to meet the holds demand,
collection development and weeding
to stay fresh, and expanding content
to new lending models and genres.
The opportunities that I see as a
result of this survey and the work
that we've been doing
in Massachusetts
and the past DPLA Fests, and
many discussions that have gone
on over the past few years are
really embodied in the IMLS grants
that are out there now to support
a national digital platform.
SimplyE that went to
New York public library
and a large number of partners.
The LEAP grant that I'm sure
Micah will talk about in detail
that we're a partner on and
many of you are partners on.
And the SimplyE for consortia
which was granted to Minitex
with a large number of partners
to develop an app for consortia
to provide much enhanced
discovery check out
and ease of reading, simplicity.
So I think our opportunity now
is to really take advantage
of the economies of scale.
Of the few that reported $10 million
in spending it's got to be double
or triple that from
what I'm guessing.
And if we can put our
buying power together,
put our technical development
power together
that we can really go places with
discoverability and simplicity.
And I thank you very much.
[ Clapping ]
>> Micah May: Thank
you Greg and Christine.
I feel like that's a perfect
set up for what's next for me.
And I have the luxury of talking
mostly about specific problems
that I've been interested in,
projects I've been working on.
And I guess before I dive into that
I guess let me thank these folks,
and very personally, because I think
what Christine said about building
and standing on the
shoulders of the projects
from before us is absolutely true.
And it's very much
true of these projects
that I've helped to
conceive and drive.
And I think specifically Greg
and Christine are two
of those shoulders.
So I met most of the partners
and found out they work in ebooks
because of the call that Christine
would convene amongst people doing
ebook work.
And so very literally I found
the other people doing this work
through her.
And similarly Greg has been a
constant voice and advocate for me
to do this in a big-scaled
way that has I think been one
of the most powerful voices saying,
"We're approaching this right."
So I think that as we think
about what's next in this space,
in my mind it is time
for a transition.
And I think the projects that
Christine gave a really nice history
of were groundbreaking,
and they were powerful,
and they proved that we can do it.
And I think that was a
really important thing
for libraries to go do and prove.
But I think they also proved
something else which is
that they demonstrated that this is
work that just screams for scale.
Once you build these
capacities you should share them
because it's very easy to
reuse them and to share them.
And so I think that we are
benefitting from the lessons learned
from those projects in that the
projects that I'm going to talk
about have been conceived in a way
that beg-scaling from
the very beginning.
And I said this at PLA
last week I'm going
to start saying it every time I talk
about this I think we are talking
precisely about building components
of a national digital
platform for libraries.
This is precisely that.
And we're starting with ebooks.
And I think this will show
that we have the capacity
to build capabilities that can
very quickly expand beyond ebooks.
And I would say even this year we're
likely to be able to handle things
like audio And it will very
quickly be clear that this is not
about ebooks, this is about
delivering library content
to patrons on library-owned
infrastructure.
So this is in my mind a first foray
into building the national
digital platform for libraries.
And I think that's how
we should conceive of it.
So I want to give another shout out
as I start this to ReadersFirst.
I think the work that our projects
have done would not have been
possible without the tremendously
successful advocacy work
of ReadersFirst to open up ebook
content and provide interoperability
between those platforms
so that you can serve it
in a library-owned environment.
So Michael Blackwell who's
in the fourth row here,
you want to give a wave, has I
think been one of many leaders
that have stepped up, and are really
helping to rejuvenate or double-down
on ReadersFirst, and the promise
of interoperability that it offers.
And I think that both
Greg and Christine hit
on something very powerful which
is the idea that our, you know,
while we are small institutions
in some cases, even NYPL compared
to the Goliaths of
the technology world
that we sometimes hold
ourselves up against,
collectively we can
be very powerful.
And I think ReadersFirst showed that
when really just a small percentage
of these distributors'
clients started saying,
"This is our content
and we should own it.
And we want the ability to take it
out and take the [inaudible] out
and serve it to users
in an interoperable way
that supports a high
quality of service."
And that principled stand worked
incredibly quickly so that whereas
in 2012 these distributors
just refused to give us APIs,
we now have high-functioning APIs
out of all the major public
library ebook distributors.
And I think the next
phase of this work,
one of the most important things
we can do is build on that success
and apply that same principle
and approach to the rest
of the library world so that we
can extend some successes we've had
focused primarily around
public circulating libraries
to also benefit academic
and school libraries
and special libraries as well.
And I think that ReadersFirst offers
us a model and a vehicle, in part,
I think there are many organizations
that can and should contribute
to this to continue
to move that forward
and give libraries the
raw materials they need
in order to own their service.
And that really starts
with interoperability.
And so I think that's a critical
underpinning of all of this work.
So with that I'm going to start by,
I mean most of you know these
projects so I'm going to try
to move through it quickly.
As you probably know the grant in
2012 that was awarded by the IMLS
to create the Library Simplified
Project now named SimplyE
as the product that came out of
that has been I think, you know,
we've been working
hard for three years.
My colleague and partner
in this, James English,
who's the Product Owner
for that is also here
and has built a beautiful
simple ebook reading experience
which has now been released.
The first instance of that
is the Open Ebooks App
that Michelle mentioned.
And that is also now available
to libraries to start using.
And my hope is that this year
we'll see many deployments
across library worlds and this
will start to become very real.
So that's ready in the sense that
the technology is up, it's working,
it's proving to be very scalable
in Open Ebooks implementation.
And it is designed to be open
source and is inexpensive
as possible for libraries to deploy.
And the first step in them
beginning to take ownership
of their relationship
with their patrons.
And I guess sort of philosophically
I'd like to emphasize
that that's why we started here.
It is the app through
which people read.
It is the primary mechanism
for discovery.
It's the touch point where
we interact with our patrons.
And what we wanted to
start with is the assertion
that these patrons are our patrons,
our customers and our relationships.
And our vendors sometimes would
like to both sell us content
and own that relationship.
And I think we have begun to reject
that and say, "If a library chooses
to provide these services through
a vendor-hosted offering then
that is fine if it's
the libraries choice."
But that cannot be our only option.
We as libraries have
the right and the need
to have the interoperability that
supports us in serving libraries
in an environment we
own and we control.
And I think SimplyE is the
vehicle for that right now.
So it allows us both to merge
all of our ebook content
from multiple distributors into one
place so that we can rationalize it
and put it all in one place,
which in turns allows us
to free our procurement
decisions of the user experience
so that we can buy from whomever
gives us the best deal whenever we
want, and that will drive
competition in the market.
And I think in some ways even
more exciting and powerful
than what SimplyE can do today is
what it's going to be able to do
to tomorrow, which is that because
we own it we can do what want
with it.
If libraries want to come together
and say that it's really critical
to be able to ingest an API feed
about programs we're running
in our branches so that we can have
push marketing and there's a pop-up
in your ereader saying,
"We're running our program
in a branch five blocks from you.
In half an hour please come join."
That's something that
we can fully build now
because this is our
experience and we own it.
This is providing library service
through library-owned channels
which I think is really the
point of all of this work.
So briefly, specifically, SimplyE
right now today can integrate
through middleware collections
that libraries own and host
on the three major
existing library vendors--
3M Bibliotheca, Baker and Taylor,
and OverDrive, the BiblioBoards
or Biblio [inaudible] API is
within weeks of being finished.
And then that, too, this year
will be able to be integrated.
And so we continue to have more
and more content that we can roll
into one better comprehensive
experience.
And I'd like to go
back to Greg's slide
about the other ebook platforms.
I think we've really turned a corner
in the last three years in that
as I talk to other distributors, so
EBSCO is a standout example of this,
they were second on Greg's slide,
they're many state libraries,
many consortia and many
individual libraries
who own ebook collections
through EBSCO.
Now EBSCO does not
yet have a content API
so it would be impossible
to merge their content
into anything but their app.
But in conversations with them in
the last month it's been clear to me
that we're in a very
different place.
So in 2012 these distributors
refused to build the APIs.
And we were trying to beat
and bludgeon and negotiate,
and we still kind of failed.
And then we started
ReadersFirst with others
that had the same experience,
the demand access to our content.
We're not there anymore.
So if you talk to EBSCO they will
tell you that they're perfectly open
to building a content API.
They plan to do it and they're
willing to build to our spec
so that we can make
these interoperable.
And that is an example of
this ReadersFirst application
that is the underpinning to be
able to doing any of this work.
So I think one of the most important
thing that libraries are interested
in this and need to do is to
start talking to their vendors
and their providers about the
importance of interoperability.
And even if it's going to take your
library another year or two or three
to roll out these platforms you
can help right now by underscoring
with your budget to your vendors
the importance of interoperability,
philosophically, fundamentally which
will do nothing but open options
for you as a library
and for other libraries.
And to Greg's survey and the
point about the financial power
of libraries, even just
within the 20 partners named
on the LEAP grant there's 28
million in econtent spent.
And so nationally we know that this
number is hundreds of millions.
So it is a substantial market.
And we are spending a lot of money.
And so if we can speak
with a unified voice
about what we want we
can change that market.
And we can start saying
to our vendors
that interoperability
is table steaks.
It's not an extra, it
is what we require.
When we buy content it's ours and
we want the ability and the right
to serve it in the best environment
for our users, and in an environment
that lets us control that.
So the next series in
this project was LEAP,
the Library eContent Access Project,
which you've all heard a lot about.
This is basically the effort to
go further and build a backend
to this system that would be
a library-owned marketplace,
a library-centric marketplace
and distributor.
So this is the whole right-hand
side of the six-part stack
at the bottom of this page.
I think this can be
built and up, hopefully,
in a pilot version
this calendar year.
So we're going to try
to push very quickly.
Again, building on Christine's
point, we're learning
from what others have done
that started before us.
And so we're conceiving this right
out of the gate as
a national platform.
Every library in the country will
be free and we will encourage them
over time to enter and buy
through this marketplace.
We'll start with ebooks but we'll
quickly move to other things.
We will continue to follow and
pursue the ReadersFirst principles
of loosely coupled architecture
that gives libraries options.
I think this offers a clear
win-win for publishers
because to the degree it
can save libraries money
that would have otherwise gone
to the distributors we will
all reinvest it in content.
And publishers recognize
that and I think are eager
for a library-owned
option in the marketplace.
And we want this to be as
decentralized as possible.
So we hope that as we work, and
this is already very much starting,
we will build close collaborations
and that this although
being incubated right now
in New York Public Library
I think we are already
in deep partner relationships
with a number of you.
In fact, many of the
successful programs
on a regional basis we're
already in deep conversations
about bringing them into formal
governance roles and sharing
with them in the incubation of LEAP.
And that includes the
Montana Library Association
that Christine talked about,
Califa and also the Denver Library
that carried the Evoke
Project forward.
So I think I'm out of time.
So I guess I'll skip this
and let you ask questions
about it if you'd like.
But I do think there's a
number of ways you can help.
And I think you're probably
here because you have questions
or something to say about this.
So we'd love to hear what
that is and have a discussion
about how we can all move
ebooks forward in libraries.
Thank you.
[ Clapping ]
>> Michelle Bickert:
Is this working?
Can you hear me?
Okay. Apparently this has
been on the entire time
so it's a good thing I didn't
say anything embarrassing.
So we only have about five
minutes left in this session.
As Micah mentioned if
any of you are coming
to the reception afterwards you
can find me or Micah or Rachel,
we have several other colleagues who
are here who can talk to Open Ebooks
or LEAP in some capacity.
We're happy to help
connect you with them.
So we'll take a couple of
questions with our time left.
That's how good we did.
>> Micah May: There's got
to be a question out there.
Or a comment?
Thank you.
I guess if there's really not
a question I've been wanting
to ask one which is I mean
you've heard us making the case
and if anyone is feeling
brave and wants
to volunteer I would be curious
of audience members what most
excites you about the opportunity
to own our ebook and our
econtent delivery channels.
What do you see as the most powerful
and compelling opportunities?
Anyone feeling brave and want
to step up and volunteer?
Why did you come to this talk?
What gets you excited about this?
Yeah. Thanks Michael.
>> Michael: [inaudible]
thank you very much.
It's certainly very exciting.
I think that libraries have
learned in the last ten years
that branding is essential
and this is going
to be an opportunity
for us to do that.
Second thing is it has been
too difficult for library users
to get access to content in
many cases, ebook content,
and if we can simplify that
and provide a better model
for the publishers to work with us
that we will see continuing
exponential increases
in library ebooks.
And libraries are not ebooks
only its econtent, and this is
yet another way to make ourselves
more relevant and present
in an increasingly digital world.
>> Micah May: I think
that's exactly right.
We need to own this
from every angle.
If I'm not seeing other
hands I guess I'd love
to build on that publisher point.
I think many of us have
talked about the need
to evolve relationships
with publishers.
And I think again projects
like Amigos
and Califa have been broken
tremendous ground there in showing
that smaller publishers are
willing to work directly even
with regional library associations,
and make their books available
through those platforms.
I think one of the goals
of the LEAP Project
which is completely supportive
of that and hopefully consistent
with it is to allow
libraries all over the country
and library organizations like
Califa and Amigos to onboard
that content to a national
marketplace.
So that we can not only buy content
on better terms but we can help
to bring those relationships
into existence
so that we can offer a more diverse
and a broader range of content
And then the second piece of that
is about getting to better terms.
And I think we have begun to
show that that's also possible.
Examples like Open Ebooks whereby
presenting the library values-based
argument we were able to get
these incredible donations
that are now making this
content free to low income.
But also other work of the ALA
Digital Content Working Group,
and actually NYPL directly pushing
with libraries I think
multiple voices
from the library community have
helped both to bring libraries back,
or publishers back into
the library market in 2012,
and can now go further in working
directly with those publishers
to get us the better deals.
And I think that's one of the
important points about why we need
to take ownership of this whole
pipeline, this whole channel
because it's pretty clear
to many of us I think
that the commercial distributors
from whom we buy books their
incentives are just not
well aligned.
If we get a better price term,
if we get a better term in terms
of options they don't
make any more money.
And that just, in fact, costs
them money because now they have
to go redoing their systems
to accommodate that term.
So we need an advocate that
is a sophisticated sort
of a business advocate to deal
with publishers especially
the biggest publishers.
And I think we can also
benefit tremendously
from a distributed capacity
that allows libraries all
over the country to be not only a
provider of content but a channel
for making content discoverable
and available in libraries
by working directly with
publishers, and potentially
in the future even authors in
their region to bring that content
into libraries and to
make it discovered.
Other questions or comments?
>> Michelle Bickert: It's 3:47 now.
>> Micah May: Okay.
So we're technically
two minutes past.
>> Michelle Bickert:
Thank you to my colleagues
for joining me on this panel.
Thank you to you all
for joining us today.
Hopefully you can find
some cookies out there
because we've got one more session.
[inaudible] some coffee.
But thank you all for coming.
[ Clapping ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.